اهلا من جديد اعلنت مجموعه فورمات
الامريكيه الملكه للفيسبوك انستغرام
وواتساب انهاء خدماتي اكثر من احد 10,000
من موظفها في اكبر عمليه تسريح منذ
تاسيسها قبل 18 عاما يمثل العدد حوالي 13%
من القوى العامله في الشركه واوضحت متى
انها ستدفع 16 اسبوع من الراتب الاساسي
واسبوعين اضافيين لكل سنه من الخدمه وجميع
الاجازات المدفوعه المتبقيه كجزء من حزمه
انهاء الخدمه
بعد ايام قليله من تخفيض شركه تويتر عدد
موظفيها الى النصف كوسيله لخفض التكاليف
بعد استحواذ الى الماسكا عليها وتعاني
المنصات والالكترونيه التي يرتكز نموذجها
الاقتصادي على الاعلانات من خفض المعنين
لانفاقهم بسبب تضخم العالمي وارتفاع
معدلات الفائده
هذا وقال الرئيس التنفيذ المجموعه متى ذكر
بيرد في رساله لموظف الشركه انه يتحمل
مسؤوليت هذه القرارات اضاف ذكر برج عند
الانكماش الاقتصاديه الكليه وزياده
المنافسه وخساره الاعلانات تسببت في
انخفاض العائلات كثيره عما كان يتوقعه
مشيرا الى انه كان يتوقع استمرار الطفره
التجاره الالكترونيه والنشاط عبر الانترنت
التي حدثت خلال جريحه كورونا وذكر في
رسالته ان الشركه تعمل على تمديد فتره
تجميد توظيف حتى الربع الاول من العام
القادم مع عدد قليل من الاستثناءات اكد
ذكر برج انه سيراقب الاداء والكفاءه
التشغيليه وعوامل الاقتصاد الكلي الاخرى
لتحديد ما اذا كان ينبغي استئناف التوظيف
فيه مستقبلا
ويعمل في مجموعه متى حوالي 87 الف موظف في
انحاء العالم بحسب ارقام نهايه سبتمبر
ايلولا الماضي وتراجعت الارباح الصافيه
للمجموعه باكثر من 50% على اساس سنويا
لتبلغ حوالي اربعه مليارات و 400 مليون
دولار في الفصل الثالث من العام الجاري
وفقدت اسهم ومتى حوالي 70% تقريبا من
قيمتها وقالت متى ان متوسطه السعر اعلانها
انخفض بنسبه 18% على اساس سنويا ومع
احتمال حدوث ركود اقتصادي للاجئت شركات
امريكيه لتقليص الانفاق وتسريح جزء من
قوتها العامله وبينما لا تزال هذه
الاجراءات في طور التخطيط والاعلان فان
اخرى عامرت للتنفيذ فورا متابعه بعضا منها
[موسيقى]